hello hello hello how's it going guys oh
it's a thrill to be here with you guys
so my name is Jason Silva and I am the
host of brain games on the National
Geographic Channel which often looks at
our perceptions and misperceptions of
the world and I think that there's a lot
of misperceptions when it comes to
technology and disruption so I'm
extremely passionate about human
creativity I'm extremely passionate
about human imagination and this has
turned into a passion for technology and
innovation because I believe that
ultimately technology is the embodiment
of human creativity in the world
technology is the literalization
of human imagination in the world
technology is the human mind turned
inside out technology is how we
impregnate the world with mind and
creativity in fact the cognitive
philosophers David Chalmers and Andy
Clarke described technology as a kind of
scaffolding of our minds that extends
our thoughts our reach and our vision
and it has always been so a hundred
thousand years ago in the savannahs of
Africa when early hominids first picked
up a stick on the ground and used that
stick to reach a fruit on a really high
tree we've been using our sticks our
tools our instruments to extend our
limits to transcend our boundaries to
redefine our limitations and in turn our
tools and technologies have transformed
us as the philosopher Marshall McLuhan
used to say we build the tools and then
those tools build us now today it's safe
to say we live in the age of radical
disruption we live in the age of
transformation we live in the age in
which it feels like the rug is being
pulled from underneath our feet
everything is changing so fast
everything is being up ended everything
is being called into question it's
overwhelming it's really exciting but it
can also be terrifying right we're
feeling these disrupt
in real time but the truth is these
disruptions have always occurred
throughout our history
it's just that they used to accrue over
many generations the world didn't really
change very much within one's own
lifetime back in the day the change is
accrued over many lifetimes but today
the changes are happening in real time
the changes can be felt within our own
careers our own jobs change within weeks
and months it's happening now and the
question is why why is it speeding up
why do we feel it now if this has always
been the case if technology has always
disrupted humanity why does it feel so
overwhelming lately and this has to do
with the exponential nature of
technological progress I don't have to
tell you guys about Moore's law you've
probably heard the term used a million
times right the nature of technological
change is exponential but you see the
problem is that the human brain evolved
in a world that was linear and that was
local so our intuition about change is
linear our instinct about change is
linear we can be educated we can be told
a thousand times they can beat it over
our heads technology changes exponential
you have to understand the implications
of Moore's law so you can plan
exponentially for these transformations
again our intuition continues to be
linear it's just not our wiring we're
future blind because we have this linear
lens we see with this lens we see
through our lens but we don't see the
lens themselves so we don't realize that
we're continuing to think linearly in
the age of Exponential's so here's a
very very quick example used by the
famed futurist Ray Kurzweil who runs
engineering at Google at the moment and
he's a famous futurist he's basically
mr. singularity himself and the example
that Illustrated at least for me in a
way that I never forgot the difference
between linear change and exponential
change is his famous 30 steps example
really easy if you take 30 linear
steps one two three four five by step
thirty where are you
you're at thirty thirty linear steps
thirty changes over time right thirty
steps gets you two thirty but if you
take the same amount of steps
exponentially two four sixteen by step
thirty you're actually at a billion so
this is where it gets interesting thirty
linear steps gets you two thirty thirty
exponential steps gets you to a billion
and technology advances in these
exponential steps that's the reason the
smartphone in your pocket today is a
million times cheaper a million times
smaller yet a thousand times more
powerful than what used to be a 60
million dollar supercomputer that was
half a building in size forty years ago
what used to be half a building now fits
in your pocket that's exponential
progress this is a thousand times more
powerful in a million times cheaper in a
million times smaller than what used to
be sixty million bucks in occupy half a
building forty years ago and those
exponential trends they're not stopping
so in the next twenty five years this
will likely dematerialize into a blood
cell sized device interacting with our
bodies and brains and continuing to
reverse-engineer us from inside out this
is where we're heading
but we're halfway there the tools to
change the world are now in everybody's
hands the supercomputers of yesterday
are now in everybody's hands a young kid
in rural Africa with a smartphone has
better communications technology than a
head of state than a president had 25
years ago how does this change what
becomes possible how does this change
what we become capable of Steven Johnson
in his marvelous book where
good ideas come from a natural history
of innovation talks about the adjacent
possible the adjacent possible is a way
of seeing things it's a lens through
which to see the world the adjacent
possible is a shadow from the future
that hovers over the present and
provides a map of all the ways in which
the present can reinvent itself the
adjacent possible is a way of looking
upon the world and imagining what might
be thinking exponentially right once the
mind is stretched by a new idea it never
returns to its original position we must
remember that we're like Dorothy and
we're about to go to Oz we are
stretching our cognitive Kansas so that
we can see things exponentially because
exponentially everything becomes
possible and even when it's scary
everything good and great begins at the
edge of our comfort zone at the edge of
next as this event is titled we are on
the cusp of a transformation of the
human Enterprise that we can barely even
begin to fathom as Eric Davis wrote when
everything becomes linked with
everything else matter becomes mind as
we impregnate the world with sensors as
we plug a eye into everything the same
way we electrified the planet now we
cognate eyes the planet as Kevin Kelley
has written in Wired magazine how does
this change our scope of possibilities
out as this change the game we are a
hybrid of biological and non-biological
intelligence we are distributing our
cognition and our intelligence we are
creating a hive mind we are cloaking the
planet in a fabric of AI that will
change the game
goal is to inspire you to embrace these
disruptions to embrace exponential
change as exponential opportunity right
to transcend the bin there's and done
that of the adult mind and see the world
as if through the eyes of a child
everything is possible everything is
possible but at the end of the day
technology is a double-edged sword
technology extends our capability in
both positive and or negative ways it's
up to us so the story we tell ourselves
about ourselves matters because it
determines our actions in the world and
this is the inspiration behind my work
I'm a digital storyteller in addition to
my work on brain games and I want to
start actually by showing you a video an
dance them on the human capacity to
overcome our boundaries to hopefully
Electrify you with a sense of optimism
please play the first video to be human
is to be trans human so there's a great
line by Shakespeare in which he says we
know what we are we know not what we may
be and in the age of accelerating
technologies in which we extend the
cognitive reach of our minds the
perimeters of our humaneness with these
extensions of self these exoskeletons
these technological scaffoldings you
know the wings of our aircrafts and the
signals traveling through our smartphone
sending our thoughts electrified at the
speed of light across oceans of sky we
redefine and extend what it means to be
human
Edward o Wilson says
we have actually decommissioned natural
selection and now we must look deep
within ourselves and decide what we wish
to become we are now the chief agents of
evolution we have reversed engineered
the software of biology and about to
rewire and upgrade and redefined what it
is to be a homo sapien Juan Enriquez
uses the term homo evolutis the being
that evolves itself that transforms
itself right reycarts while we didn't
stay in the caves we haven't stayed on
the planet biology just another membrane
to be transcended you know Marvin Minsky
used to say will robots inherit the
earth
yes they will but they will be our
children you know I love this idea
because we hear the term transhumanism
and what it means to be human is to be
trans human we are the species that
transforms and transcends we never
stopped we always did it's what we are I
believe I have an abiding belief in the
human capacity to overcome our
boundaries and I'm incredibly excited as
I've tried to convey about exponential
change because I believe again that
exponential change means exponential
opportunity now we've all seen these
exponential transformations effect the
world of digital technology we've seen
information technology cloak the planet
and transformation and I travel around
the world and I get to talk to audiences
about embracing exponential change and
often people will tell me you know what
I buy that because I've seen it there's
evidence for the trends are clear with
information technology but what about
the world of flesh and concrete right
the sort of world that we dwell the
physical world in which we dwell
certainly that is not subject to
exponential change right well it turns
out that the world of flesh and concrete
is now also becoming an information
technology and thus also subject to
these exponential trends for example
biology so now we are entering the age
of BI
Oh technology biotechnology means
mastering the information processes of
biology because it turns out that we are
alphabetic all the way down
DNA is code our DNA is our little
software programs we are alphabetic
beings all the way down and we are
increasingly leveraging harnessing the
capacity to turn biology into a
programmable medium the physicist
Freeman Dyson has talked about a very
near future where a new generation of
artists will be writing genomes with the
fluency that Blake and Byron and
Shakespeare wrote versus what's gonna
happen when our artists and engineers
get to use biology as their canvas get
to use biology as their paintbrush what
are we gonna make
how will we self modify how will this
change medicine and it turns out that
advances in biotechnology are moving
along at the predictably exponential
rates gene sequencing is advancing three
times faster than Moore's Law it's going
three times faster than exponential
we're already seeing it the XPrize
foundation recently had a contest for
the first medical tricorder that a group
of technologists could create smartphone
sized device that could diagnose you
better than ten board-certified doctors
lab-on-a-chip technologies they call
them Google's Larry Page co-founded
calico the California Life Extension
company a software company for biology
they get this in Silicon Valley they got
a Time magazine cover story called
Google and the end of death see it's not
just about reprogramming our genes away
from disease it's not even about getting
rid of cancer the same way we might rid
our computer of a software virus but
increasingly longevity increasing our
health span increasing our vitality
boosting our cognitive capacities who
knows when craig venter the creator of
the first synthetic organism was asked
do you worry that you're playing God his
response which I think was brilliant was
who's playing I'm telling you
very exciting potentially game-changing
for Homo sapiens but all technologies
are double-edged swords so of course
there are a host of concerns DIY
synthetic biology means that the crazy
kid can create a pathogen in his garage
so definitely something to be concerned
of also but I believe it's gonna change
the game then you have nanotechnology
the seminal book on nanotechnology by
Eric Drexler was called engines of
creation and that's literally what
nanotechnology implies nanotechnology
will allow us to pattern atoms right at
the level of the atoms pattern and
program atoms the same way we pattern
ones and zeros in digital technology and
you've seen what we can do by moving
around ones and zeros in digital tech
with nanotech the physical world becomes
a programmable medium we'll have
software that writes its own hardware
we'll have buildings that assemble
themselves computers that build better
computers and by the way nanotech exists
in nature you plant a seed in the soil
and it turns into a tree that seed is an
information file it instructs the matter
around it to turn into a tree nanotech
is there and again advances in
nanotechnology you've probably heard of
the term nanobots little nano sized
devices in our bodies and brains
repairing us at the molecular level this
is also coming and of course AI
artificial intelligence non-biological
intelligence advancing exponentially
scaring most people for the idea of the
Terminator scenario or the AI is rising
up against us I happen to think
like kurtzweil and other optimists that
will merge with our AI these will be
narrow intelligences that specialize in
certain things and will become a hybrid
as I've mentioned before the human mind
according to the cognitive philosophers
David Chalmers and Andy Clarke emerges
in the feedback loops between brains
tools and environments we are mediated
by our environments our environments
already shape our thoughts we interact
with non-biological tools and these
tools change how we think so
the VY true vien man if drawn today
would have probably a smartphone in his
hand and that would be an appendage that
would be a part of his physiology we
need to get over our skin back bias and
realize that we've exceeded our skin
that technology is our second skin that
technology is our exoskeleton that
technology is the mirror that reflects
us back to ourselves and these three
overlapping revolutions right biotech
nanotech and AI together are leading us
towards an event horizon some say it's
kind of like staring into the Sun you
know you can't quite see because it's so
bright just kind of like other
singularities that happened in the past
like the emergence of language you know
when we were early primate so we were
really bright like the chimpanzee but
try to explain to a chimpanzee the
nuances of Shakespearean sonnets he just
lacks the wetware no matter how clever
it is to think about the rich symbolic
world that language has opened up for us
us we're the chimps now and on the back
of these revolutions AI biotech nanotech
we will transform ourselves into
something else
you've probably heard of Yuval hari's
bestseller homo Deus which is the sequel
to sapiens where he maps how these
technologies will change the world or
rate kurtzweil as the singularity is
near when humans transcend biology or as
some call in Silicon Valley refer to
this moment as the rapture of the Nerds
because there's almost like a religious
quality to it like here we go except
this is based on data-driven
extrapolation so it's not just blind
abiding belief it's hey look how far
we've come look how fast we've gotten
here the math works where we're gonna be
in 25 years when thinking exponentially
whoa and this next video paints a
picture because I believe that this
Marshall McLuhan said it's always been
the artist who realizes that the future
is the present and uses his work to
prepare the grounds for it please show
the future of us so let's talk about the
future of us what does that even mean
the future of us it's a look at what
comes next
it's a look at what might be because
today exponentially emerging
technologies are transforming what's
possible they're helping us overcome
transcend even biological limitations
the very rules of what it is to be human
are up for grabs we're rewriting the
software of life with biotechnology
we're turning matter into a programmable
medium with nanotechnologies well
creating sentient Minds with artificial
intelligence that are not bound by the
limitations of biology these three
overlapping revolutions PNR genetic and
technology and robotics together will be
leveraged to lead us towards a black
hole life impossible to fathom
singularity it's like staring into the
Sun a moment of a rousing symphonic
climax when all of my leverage
together transcends its biological
origins and we become something more
people worry about the ai's in the sand
well as Kurzweil says that's gonna be us
the future of us is our studio now the
world is changing very fast I mean that
much is obvious
you know I sound like a broken record
here but it's what's happening and so
the question then becomes what's going
on here what do we do is this a good
thing is this a bad thing should we be
scared should we be excited now I am of
the opinion that this is an
inevitability I am of the opinion that
this is an emergent property of the
cosmos the cell same self-organizing
principles that turn single celled
organisms into multicellular organisms
that eventually led to us seems to have
been now birthed out of us in the form
of technology I mean I think there's no
better way to explain simultaneous
inventions throughout history every
great innovation every great person that
ever came up with a transformative
original idea there was always like four
or five other people around the world
they were on the cusp of discovering the
same thing I mean it's kind of wild when
you think about it and Kevin Kelley who
started Wired magazine and he's kind of
a techno prophet himself beautifully
articulate writer he refers to
technology as he calls it the seventh
kingdom of life he calls it something
that is subject to the same evolutionary
forces as biological evolution the name
the Technium it's such a wild idea
technology as an organism technology is
something that is literally alive right
we are the sex organs of technology
technology uses us to perpetuate itself
in this symbiotic self-reinforcing
feedback loop that is again accelerating
so if this is a natural thing right
what is the attitude we should take
rather than fear it we should just
realize that we're just along for the
ride and as Kevin Kelly has also echoed
imagine how impoverished human culture
would be if we didn't invent the
technology of the oil painting in time
for Vincent van Gogh and his masterful
work or the technology of the musical
instrument in time for Beethoven and
Mozart these were all technologies even
our neocortex is a technology late late
in the game of human evolution without
it we wouldn't have our imagination
probably we wouldn't be able to conceive
of things that don't yet exist right the
technology of language in time for
Shakespeare what new forms of human
creativity beauty and radiant glory will
be made possible on the back of new
technologies we cannot even begin to
imagine just to see what we're gonna
make we should be enthusiastic
participants in engendering the tools
and technologies that will change the
world and are changing the world we
might as well be active participants
rather than passive observers we are the
captains of this spaceship earth right
there's no passengers just crew in this
next video that I want to show you goes
even deeper into this subject of tack
and nature right we're smack in the
middle between the Bourne and the made
it's all on a continuum because we're
finding increasingly actually that the
more sophisticated and advanced our
algorithms our systems are man-made our
techno systems become the more they
start to actually mirror systems in
nature so then it starts to sound like
The Twilight Zone like the more artful
and sublime our engineering and our
designs the more that starts to mirror
systems found in nature like the way the
tcp/ip protocols that govern information
flow of traffic on the Internet are
organized like the neurons in our brain
what the hell is that please
show the patterns video you know there's
a mind expanding idea that smashes the
false duality between nature and
technology the realization that nature
and technology are one and the same a
continuing smack in the middle between
the Bourne and the major is summed up in
two lines to understand is to perceive
patterns that moment when the dots
connect you see the guest out long view
and you see the big picture this notion
of patterns for example Paul Stamets has
written about the mycelial archetype and
how the information sharing systems that
comprise the Internet a man-made system
mirror the neurons in our brain a
natural system which in turn mirror
computer models of dark matter in the
universe they all share the exact same
intermingled bill a mental structure
it's unbelievable
or for example the fact that forager
ants when they hunt for food their
patterns of hunting mirror the tcp/ip
protocols that govern information flow
of traffic on the Internet same patterns
jeffrey west from the Santa Fe Institute
tells us that cities are actually like
organisms they have metabolic rates and
the alleys are like capillaries fly an
airplane look at a city from the sky it
looks like a motherboard it looks like a
microchip information arranged evolution
live sentience mind to understand is to
perceive these patterns there is no
duality between nature and technology it
is all one and the same
[Music]
so obviously it's really fun to marvel
it's really fun to geek out it's really
fun to dive into the rabbit hole right I
mean we are Alice and we are in
Wonderland but at the end of the day why
well I believe these tools and
technologies I believe these superpowers
are only worthwhile if we're going to
use them to make this a better world
right to extend our hands towards one
another with compassion and empathy and
love I mean I get it yeah it sounds
tacky cheesy but the point is this is
what it's about to bring people together
to overcome
boundaries to address a dress the Grand
Challenges of humanity and solved them
once and for all
Bill Clinton had a time magazine cover
story a couple years ago called a case
for optimism in which he cited a United
Nations study I believe from like 2010
that had determined that the cellphone
was the greatest invention in human
history to pull people out of poverty
that's what I'm talking about
and in spite of the doom and gloom
perpetuated by media enterprises that
are just focused on getting our amygdala
fired up so that we pay attention the
world is actually now the least violent
than it's ever been in all of human
history bar none check out the work of
Steven Pinker the better angels of our
nature is the name of his book his TED
talk the myth of violence maps out all
the numbers the chances of a human dying
at the hands of another human today are
the lowest and they've ever been in all
of human history you see the news you
get really scared it's like everything's
going to hell no it's not we've never
been in safer more prosperous times ever
it's just that we have the capacity to
amplify what's wrong but that's good
because now we can put our effort to
address what's wrong and fix it now one
thing that's exciting about exponential
technologies is that young people
increasingly and hopefully many of you
have this ambition that they can do
something that's game-changing and
become real wealthy in the process right
everybody wants to come up with the next
startup conceived over the next
algorithm that will make them
billionaires the next Mark Zuckerberg
and hey look that ambition is great be
ambitious think bigger than ever before
but how about reframing the definition
of billionaire people like Peter
Diamandis and numerous others have
talked about this at places like
singularity University I love the
concept I made a video about it in fact
and the idea is that in the age of
exponential technologies
millionaire is no longer somebody with a
billion dollars although that's nice a
billionaire in the age of exponential
technologies in the age of big data in
the age of transformation in the age of
the Internet of Things in the age of
rapid change and disruption the new
billionaire is somebody who can conceive
of a disruption that impacts the lives
of a billion people in a positive way
that this should be your new metric that
this should be your ambition that it's
actually possible it is within the realm
of your adjacent possible to come up
with an idea that can positively touch a
billion people what a reason to get up
in the morning guys you know something
happens to astronauts when they go into
orbit when astronauts go into orbit many
of them report something that's been
called by psychologists the overview
effect see when you actually see the
Earth from space you have a cognitive
shift in your self-image
you're not lung you're no longer
identifying just with the person you see
in the mirror you're no longer
identifying with your tribe or your race
or your nationality
now you're identifying with the whole
thing right the whole planet of which
you are a node a neuron you are a part
of this larger system now all of us
don't get to go into orbit unfortunately
but advances in storytelling
technologies like virtual reality I
believe can become a tool for increasing
our empathy and compassion in the world
so that we make the necessary shift in
our minds that will then govern our
actions in the world that we can use
these transformative technologies to
become billionaires to aspire to touch a
billion souls in a positive way I
believe this is also the solution to the
epidemic of stress and angst and
depression that we're seeing in the
world we need a bigger purpose well
here's the purpose
here it is become a new billionaire so I
made a video about it I shot it with a
smartphone to prove the point that you
could use the tool in your pocket to
tell a story and spread it and touch a
billion minds we got like 2 million
views so that means 2 million mine's not
a billion yet but you get the point
please show the captains of spaceship
earth we live in a world of exponential
technological advancements what this
literally means that we have new
construction kits for our reality new
tools with which to probe at the
adjacent possible so consider the
implications right as Marshall McLuhan
used to say first we build the tools and
then the tools build us we are designed
by what we have designed there are these
feedback loops of mind tool and world
that radically redefined our boundaries
that radically transform what it means
to be human to be human today is to
criss cross the skies to the human today
is to create techno social wormholes to
my community
and these days and so what do we do well
we need to radically reach out to one
another in ways that we haven't before
there's a great line that says empathy
rarely extends beyond our line of sight
in other words it's out of sight it is
out of mind but if anything is wireless
communication technologies are radically
giving us the astronaut overview effect
we are seeing the big picture we are
seeing of spaceship and what shall we do
we need to extend our hands to one
another we've never had such tools to
overcome all of the limitations of our
humanity we have the power and the will
have the capacity the creative capacity
to overcome our limits today billions of
us leads into one another
a global brain what is the new
definition of billionaire the new
definition of billionaire is he who will
positively affect the lives of a billion
people he or she will reach out and say
I will positively affect the lives of a
billion keep this should be our goal
this is our responsibility here's our
chance hopefully that's a message that
resonates guys and again I encourage you
these videos are all on my youtube
channel shots of awe watch them share
them show them to your kids etc I call
these videos shots of awe and the reason
is because it all comes down to that
particular emotion that I'm trying to
instill in you guys today I know that
for me it's all about aw now what is aw
a recent studies at Berkeley and
Stanford describe aw as an experience of
such perceptual expansion such
perceptual vastness that you have to
reconfigure your mental maps of the
world in order to assimilate to
accommodate that new experience right
because you know we all grow up we
develop these mental maps of the world
right the bin there isn't done that's of
the adult mind so there's not a lot of
new stuff that gets in we've seen it all
before we rely on these maps it's
energy-efficient our brain is at rest it
doesn't have to engage with new
information it's relying on the old maps
it's what keeps us from wanting to be
disrupted but it turns out that
cognitive disruption experiences of
astonishment experiences of awe that
immerse us that arrest us that crack us
open right whether it's the first time
you saw the Grand Canyon or the first
time you saw it images of the Hubble
Space Telescope's Deep Field photograph
right as it mainline space and time
through the optic nerve I mean that is
what aw is about I remember reading an
article by Ross Anderson in which he
said about the Hubble that through the
sheer aesthetic force of its discoveries
the sheer esthetic force of its
discoveries the Hubble distills the
complex abstractions and complexities of
astrophysics into singular expressions
of color and light
that vindicate Keith's famous couplets
beauty is truth truth is beauty that is
aw now when I think about these
technologies when I think about
exponential change when I think about
super computers shrinking from building
sized machines to devices in our pockets
that warp space and time every second
for billions of minds to communicate
across the planet without friction that
we are living in astonishing times an
awe-inspiring times and it turns out
that when we make that shift in
perception when we owe ourselves the
experience leaves lasting cognitive
benefits increased creativity increased
well-being a deeper sense of meaning and
when you're odd it acts as an
anti-inflammatory on your organism so
blowing your mind is good for you it's
beneficial it's medicinal so I'll leave
you with that and the very last video on
the transformative power of aw please
show it
[Music]
so I think a lot about the contrast
between banality and wonderful between
disengagement and radiant ecstasy
between being unaffected by the
here-and-now being absolutely ravished
emotionally by it and I think one of the
problems were human beings is mental
habits once we create a comfort zone we
rarely step outside of that comfort zone
but the consequence of that is a
phenomenon known as hedonic adaptation
over stimulation - the same kind of
thing the same stimuli again and again
and again renders says stimuli invisible
your brain is already mapped it in its
own head and you no longer literally
have to be engaged by that we have eyes
yet see not ears that hear not and
hearts that neither feel nor understand
there's a great book called the
wondering brain that says that one of
the ways that we elicit wonder is by
scrambling the self temporarily so that
the world can seep in the theory Miller
says is in a blade of grass when given
proper attention becomes an infinitely
magnificent world in itself you know
Darwin said attention if sudden enclosed
graduates in surprise and this and to
astonish and this into stupefied
amazement
that's what rapture is that's what
illumination is that's what that sort of
infinite comprehending aw that human
beings love so much and so how do we do
that how do we mess with our perceptual
apparatus in order to have the kind of
emotional and aesthetic experience from
life that we render most meaningful
because we all know those moments are
there those are the moments that will
make final cut only in these moments we
experience afresh the hardly bearable x2
direct energy exploding on our nerve
endings this is the Reb static ecstatic
bursting forth of awe that expands our
perceptual parameters beyond all
previous limits and we literally have to
reconfigure our mental models of the
world in order to assimilate the beauty
of that download that is what it means
to be inspired the recruit of the term
is to breathe in to take it in which fit
the universe through our brains and it
comes out in the form of nothing less
than poetry we have a responsibility to
all
so there you go here we are at the edge
of next and I hope that I have given you
a little something to think about so
that you look upon this edge this
precipice not with fear and apprehension
but with excitement to make this a
better smarter more intuitive more
amazing world thank you guys so much
I'll see you on Facebook and Twitter etc
etc you guys have been beautiful thank
you thank you thank you
[Applause]